scp-682 vs scp-162  the hard-to-destroy reptile was brought  in front of the nightmarish contraption  known as the ball of sharp a malevolent  ball of sharp objects that draws its  victims in and tears them apart 682  screen profanities as it was brought  before the ball it then extended its  deadly hooks tearing off one of 682's  forelimbs and its bottom jaw after a  violent struggle that's when 682 broke  containment dragging 162 along with it  and using it to slaughter 11 different  members of personnel as well as injuring  nearly 90 others two additional deaths  were caused during the recovery and the  researchers who had organized the cross  test were all given a disciplinary